topic is I'm talking about social media
and how it pertains to relationships so
I want to hear from the women
on a given day how many messages do you
from men interested in you
I think it depends I think if I put
stories up then they'll have more
interaction but
yeah I think it just depends really okay
that's an answer sorry and when I put
stories up yeah I'll get a couple of
fair few messages to be fair okay so how
many a day like
maybe like three four five okay so five
a day so
um
okay so go ahead I think for me
um I don't post every day and any sort
of like love or attention that I receive
from dudes is from guys I already know
or have already like had an encounter
with like met before so I don't really
get strangers like hey like what's up
like I don't really get that often but
people that I know will will show me
love okay so how many messages do you
get a day from then
like a zero okay so you get no messages
from guys interested in you do you have
a public Instagram yes yes but I don't
post often and when I do it's the people
that already know me I really get and if
I do is from like an uncle that's like
25 years older than me that I'm going to
ignore it's like once in a blue moon
so uh what about you
I don't really see them come up as much
because they go into message requests
let's say on average between maybe one
two one to two Okay guys
[Laughter]
how many how many messages do you get a
day you know what it's about when you
post if I post because I'm on my
personal trainer so if I post like a um
update from like my gym progress
then I'll get a flurry of people I might
get up
20 to 25 but on a normal day
if you post you get own if you don't
post it yeah if you're beating the women
yeah
I don't know so you get more DMS than
the girls I guess so well you know what
would you say is the quality of the
girls at DM you
um like out of every 10 what percent are
you would actually yeah maybe like 10
okay
I mean if I post it if I was to post a
trap it maybe be that forty percent okay
I just don't average sometimes you know
I might get some wins in there yeah
but nah nah but yeah usually just yeah
about 10 honestly okay yeah because the
gays
[Music]
[Laughter]
um so my account is no longer public
I've made it private and the reason why
is because my women are lovely because
women were just like and then be like oh
I love like how positive you are and
blah blah blah on social media guys are
very different there's no I don't think
I think there's a shortage of like
masculine mandam as they call it guys
so I made my account private because
guys have kept dming me
through like and then so like let's say
for example the black gay community in
London is not that big including like
mixed race guys so kind of
everyone's following everyone so some
people will see so some people would see
that I'm following them or blah blah
blah and then all and my biography says
like open-minded blah blah blah I don't
even say I'm bisexual so they'll slide
in my DMs
um and then one thing is with guys is
guys okay perfect example
I met a guy who Reviving blah blah blah
weren't really too sure if I liked him
or whatever and he was like look I
wouldn't mind if you had an affair with
a woman because she can give you
something that I can't give you but it
would have another man
he would find it offensive so how many
messages do you get a day
I can't say in a day I could say I could
get like two three a week two three a
week yeah okay what about you uh I don't
get no message I don't get no messages
that's half the deal with the fact that
I don't really I don't use social media
even when but at the same time back when
I was single
I still didn't really get messages like
that it was you having to fish rather
than the fish coming to you type of
situation not to say that women are fish
yeah
but it's like
yeah it's like you have to go there
rather than them come here which is very
different to a lot
the other situation I've heard from like
other guys I never got as well because
to guys ratio is very difficult because
a lot of girls that I've seen get a lot
more messages than a lot of guys have
seen however the guys that do get
messages get a lot and a lot of them
so you have that like one friend that
one male friend who's a 10 out of 10 who
would get 10 times more messages than
any girl however like a bell curve
situation there are more girls getting
more messages than guys right but from
what I've seen
the hottest guys wolves because it goes
to her how pergament so they want to go
for them but the best the best so if
you've got that one guy who's a 10 he's
going to get more messages than any girl
in any room in anywhere he's ever ever
got wants him
so when you guys are looking at a social
media profile um I know some of you are
in relationships but just like think
back to when you're single and you got
you looked at a profile and you have to
decide whether you would respond or not
what would you look at I look at the
fashion and what he's wearing okay so
fashion yeah yeah are you trying to see
how tall he is is that a big thing for
you I mean everyone wants someone over
six foot but I've been with guys that
are smaller than that so it doesn't
really bother me too too much to be fair
but yeah definitely fashion style what
they do okay I think pick up on
personality okay
um also guys if you want anyone to rate
your Instagrams put it in the chat and
we'll see what they think of it
um okay so fashion
um you said you want to see what he does
yeah uh what else anything else is that
not if he travels stuff like that and
just traveling well it just shows that
he probably was spontaneous and likes an
adventure yeah
um okay good I think for me
um of course yeah we want to look we
want to see what he looks like so I just
want to see if I like his face you know
um his build I am looking at Fashion I'm
looking at things that's like is he
posing with his like with his top out
like is he trying to show off the perks
like I'm trying to see if he's trying to
flaunt all of that because I'm attracted
to a dude that's confident but I also
don't want someone that's like cocky or
that like likes to put that on display
so if you see like a shirtless picture
is that a turn on or turn off it depends
on like most of the time it's a turn off
but it also depends on like how he's
posing like sometimes you can just see
some guys on their profile and they're
like giving you the eyes like smiles and
they're like doing the most and I feel
like that's Loki a bit of a turn off for
me okay
um but yeah I'm looking at like his
friends if he's posted any pictures of
his like Mom if like like what he does
um yeah I'm just kind of looking at all
of that I don't know if that makes sense
but what about you
I think for me it's just like if they
post their interest I don't
it more depends on the message for me
rather than the profile because the
profile's fake anyway like everyone's
Instagram is just a fake version of
themselves so it it would catch my eye
if they have something that they're
really passionate and interested in that
they post about that might entice me
more to reply but I think it more
depends on the message for me what type
of message would be a good message to
send you if it can make me laugh or
something funny something funny yeah or
something that would make me think like
if they said something really
interesting
[Music]
the standards are rough because it's
like I don't know what you find funny
and not funny
but that's kind of my point like it's
it's it's Instagram like it's it's all a
fake World anyway so you might as well
just give it a go and you know you never
know you've got to have that Universal
risk I mean
what about you two um good first message
to send you
to be fair it depends whether they're
good looking or not if I reply like the
message could just be hey and if it's
good looking I'll entertain it a little
bit but if the conversation's just dead
then it just spoils it
yeah for me like in the past I've had
guys that will like talk about my body
or anything like that and I don't want
to feel like I'm being sexually
objectified in any way so if he comes in
straight off the bat like oh like and
starts talking about my body I'm gonna
ignore that I'm not gonna give that any
energy I'm not too fussy but just saying
hey like how are you and just starting
up a conversation because I'm a human
being so it's like respect me talk to me
like I'm a human being I don't want you
to be on Instagram you know I don't
really post pictures that are like
sexually like provocative or anything
like that too tough I can but like I try
not to do that too can we see it yeah
[Laughter]
um I want to see if we could we look at
your yeah yeah that's fine uh is tashana
talks so
t-a-s-h-a-u-n-a talks because I was kind
of wanted to see I want to get the guys
feedback and like what they would think
of you without meeting you okay
um did you get that blessing
okay
um so you said it just matters how good
looking he is yeah first message for you
as long as it's not sexual yeah just
like say hey like what's up that's fine
did you have something you want to say
yeah I'm the same like if it's sexual I
won't respond whatsoever yeah
have you guys found that that if you
send like a sexual message first it's
like a lower response rate no sorry can
you repeat yeah I think I think um
please oh yeah tashana talks uh
t-a-s-h-a-u-n-a uh t a l k s or one word
yeah but hey hi how are you doing never
works
you get left on red most times you got
this you gotta just start conversation
yeah I mean like people the great thing
about Instagram which is better I think
than um text and get grabbing a number I
remember four people used to be a bit
annoyed if you know you go to talk to a
girl and she gives you like her socials
but the great thing about that is she
posts on there every day so there's
something that you can kind of connect
on at some point you know I mean wait
for that moment where you can kind of
connect on something and then just talk
normally you know I mean don't put
someone on a pedestal in the moment
you've done that yeah the game well were
you guys saying that if you send a
sexual message you're more likely to get
a response
obviously don't go don't go don't go 10
out of 10 a lot of games
like complimenting her body or something
like that I think there's certain
there's certain profiles that that works
within the same profiles that I wouldn't
yeah because from a guy
for everyone but it's one of those ones
because you guys said all right if you
listen if if he looks like he treats me
nice but guys do you think she'll
respond
yeah all right so I want to hear from
the guys oh yeah oh put me on blocks
yeah so what are we
but we're getting from here traveling
traveling okay I went to Disneyland it
was so fun no commentary
okay so I'm not seeing too much like
skin out yeah I haven't seen any
football posing where the better yet
yeah so she's a respectable girl she's
cute
I don't really think this is a page
where she's like looking for
yeah she just kind of just enjoying life
I used to work around there cheers
[Laughter]
vibe there as well yeah I wouldn't get
uh message her because she could be a
quick one type of message if I was to
see this Instagram yeah this is a honest
individual who's showing you situations
and I like that happen in her life that
first one that first one is like don't
look at me but look at me with the whole
jacket
a little bit I
don't know what's your Instagram he's
gonna pull it up it's Ashton Maria
they're a different
[Laughter]
we have one girl on this show we did a
show today called wife or cat lady where
are you yeah yeah you come on the show
and we had we had one percent men so all
these men were verified Millionaires and
they all had to um decide if the women
coming in were wife wifey or cat ladies
you know and this one girl that came in
it was like her boobs were like oh it
was like a see-through like top on
Instagram yeah and I was trying to tell
her I'm like I don't know if that's like
what the the millionaire maybe like the
millionaire like Ballers maybe that's a
different group but like I'm like I
don't know about the millionaire like
businessman you know
but yeah she didn't get it
yeah well she was very she was very
beautiful oh see she didn't need to do
that yeah no that's what I was telling
her because I was like I was like I
probably would have put her top like 10
20 of beauty she's so beautiful and I
was just like why would you put that
like yeah no need I was like that's like
being born 610 yeah and not playing
basketball
and bowling
that's that's interesting she needs more
people to run I just said tell her that
she's attractive in the face yeah I told
her she could come back
um if she deleted three of these
pictures on Instagram
she was very attached to the Instagram
okay she was a very nice girl but I was
like you're very attached to the insta
she's comparing herself to whoever she
idolizes on there so she might see some
women that all comes down to
self-confidence no but not but there
might be a woman that she finds she
might look at cardi B and think raw if I
was if I was like if I was inside girls
I'm under you know what I mean so she
kind of trust wants to mimic that and
she thinks that that is gonna get her
what she needs in it you know what I
mean do you find it weird that like a
lot of girls speaking again this is a
very general statement but a lot of
girls in that kind of respect will look
at idols and and mimic what they look
like but a lot of guys will look at
their idols and mimic what they act like
and do
um right but we focus more on respect
and I think with women sometimes could
be more of an attention visual because
how many people have cardi b as their
role model JLo you see exactly exactly
53 years
[Music]
who their role model is it's like Samuel
Jackson or something I was trying to
think of one good feminine role model in
the media today yeah like that's in Main
Street
model for me she's a like she does like
YouTube videos okay but she's not like
anywhere near as big as someone like
Beyonce or cardi B just pearly things
[Laughter]
uh do you want to pull up the Instagram
okay what are we thinking
that's the whole podcast number one so
therefore she gets a point because she
was on my podcast
this picture here
you know what's really important the
captions
can we can we pull it back
you see that picture another adventure
okay that one looks proper that picture
would make a bisexual straight again on
your stuff you're sick you know
all right all right she's cool let me
see what she say uh get small what type
of message would you guys send as an
opener to her
it'll be it'll be
I'm not trying to give too much away but
it'll be usually be Story related
something related to whatever you're
posting that right now what Adventure do
you want to go in there
[Laughter]
if I post it like back in July last year
like you went somewhere and then you
don't really want to talk about that
right now but if you're in Dubai right
now or somewhere you can talk about that
maybe you know but going through her
page I normally the pictures are uh a
given but I like I like to look at their
statuses as well what they're captioning
the things you know what I mean yeah the
single eyes do like because it's one of
those one Pages where you're like okay
you see enough
in the pictures to be like okay if I was
to message this person like I said
before when guys message like will she
respond she might she might depending on
what you say right so what your
Instagram gives off you have to come
with like really a student you have to
be really on your stuff with yours
yes it's Funko
it's not funny girl but fun girl
without meeting her like what type of
person would you have thought she was
before probably seen in the nightclubs
out there and stuff I've seen you out I
haven't but
yeah what are you in the nightclubs or
no I used to a lot when I was younger
but now it's more events like bars stuff
like that I don't really go out to the
clubs too too much certified nights
outside yeah cocktail bars two for one
before seven yes okay I know I've seen
you before
do any other guys want to volunteer
their Instagrams let's do it man
what's the message you've ever sent to a
girl oh
um what the ones that you have to send a
message and put your phone down and look
away
like a wild person oh first message oh
no don't I don't need to know
probably like a uh probably you know I
think if if she's abroad you get a
little bit more confidence in it
when you're gonna quit playing and just
move to London you know what I mean
those kind of ones
sometimes I would do funny ones that are
only funny to me like I can see you
that's the message
[Laughter]
what's your back signal with you like a
couple pictures you like the story so if
I like your pictures more than one okay
you know
you get a private message or something
like that then I kind of react to that
where it's a female or a male but a
female is very different where
I'm very it's very different with a
female because I'm kind of more romantic
type so I'm a face-to-face person anyway
I'm old school like pretend social media
didn't didn't exist so with a female
it'd be like let's let's go catch a bite
let's go to a cocktail but and I think
as time go on
I'm kind of the same thing with guys
it's not just a thing where I just want
to talk anyone can be anyone on social
media or on the phone I want to feel
your Vibe by the way you talk the way
you hold yourself as a person your body
language and and that's it because
that's what Wows me and that's what gets
here and if you've got me here yeah so
you're a little female you've got me and
you obviously know like when uh what
kind of girls or guys to that you need
to take on a date and you know which
which ones you can just bring back
like what guys are different though yeah
because guys as many of you know I was
just banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible